rising empires turn your biz into a
brained Matt wanted to help a lot of
people he believed that beautifying the
environment maids life on earth better
so he spent the last three years
building his landscaping business care
for lawns and he wanted to grow he even
hired an advisor Jared the first advice
Jared gave was changed the name what
no careful ones is great I'm not
throwing three years of brand awareness
down the tubes Matt dug in his heels but
not to be deterred jared explained when
people see the name of the business they
instantly get a feeling from that name
and whether it's a big feeling or a
small one that feeling matters these are
pretty nice name right sure but yeah
yeah your current name can hold its own
it's better than Jo's plumbing or s
smart but is your name Empire level men
could you see care for lawns becoming a
global brain could you see names from
this list becoming part of the language
part of the culture or use as a verb
like I googled that we're name drops
with pride on t-shirts and tattoos
everywhere sure I think they could why
not man okay it's possible but not
likely a linguist might say this so
weird needs widespread use you want a
word to have a nice long lifespan it
needs a good shelf life and you want to
make sure that the word has a meaning
words take a long time to sort of settle
into the language and a brand expert
might say this naming your company is up
there with being as challenging as
coming up with the idea it's that I
really represents the essence of your
brand that's going to be memorable easy
to say it's gonna be something with a
demain name is available usually it was
that they were easy to remember and we
love the way that they felt when you
said them there's something like vinco
Google or support it's just really cool
easy names point is the syllables
punchiness
meaning longevity and other aspects of a
brand's name matter
you put any thought into those when you
chose care for lawns well if you neglect
these things your name ends up average
and an average name pushes you to an
average impact I don't know
careful ones clearly communicates what
we do it's better than choosing some
weird confusing name look Matt don't
choose ego over Empire I'm not gonna
force you to listen but if Nike is smart
enough to change from Blue Ribbon sports
I believe you can do the same
blue-ribbon founders read that
successful names have two syllables and
at least one exotic letter so they
became Knightly and it made a huge
impact if you want to go down in history
like Nike I'll help but if you want to
disappear like countless other care for
long types I'm at work it's your call
Matt froze like a deer in headlights did
he really want to walk away from this
Empire opportunity just because his ego
was attached to care for lawns it was
then that Matt had a lightbulb moment
sure it's scary to rebrand everything
but better to admit the truth and do it
sooner than later especially if he wants
to go beyond being a small business all
right let's do it
yes okay so we want to have an evocative
name one that inspired the feeling just
from its sound a catchy one that has
meaning integrity and longevity
how about bland care that's two
syllables that's a bit better two
syllables or less isn't a rule but it's
great to aim for usually though blending
two words isn't unique enough compound
is a start but it's low ebb compounding
is when we take to complete or partially
complete words and put them together to
become what or fix phrases such as
well-known welcome and bus-stop it's
better for product names like Gmail not
empires like Google more examples of
this compound word thing are chopped up
auto-tune tiny Buddha as an empire
builder if you're not aiming to create
language and evolve culture you're
missing a mark what about Facebook okay
Facebook got away with slapping
two words together but their own
acquisition Instagram is quickly
overtaking hmm how about Sylvan
landscaping my key name there's active
not a victory this one comes from the
data nature
nice that's meaningful creative but come
up
not nearly as tacky or scalable ignite
write your names often your first
impression on your audience it can be
something they value or something they
recoil from or just something they
dismiss your name can do a lot of work
for you so let's look at Empires
immediate right notice any patterns here
Matt well they're short that's for sure
yep plus they tend to create language
they're broad enough to be used on any
product but they're focused enough to
symbolize something they're memorable
and pronounceable and many of these
brands have the best to admit their
original name stuck so they change them
uber began as a goober cap they dropped
the cab through the cogs regulation
issues but it was a fantastic move brand
wise
Apple began as Apple computers
incorporated not bad but it's too long
too specific and too uncool to count as
an empire so if it came out Google began
his background and I think the change
speaks for itself
hey I just thought of one that goes
against everything you said sure what is
it
coca-cola oh you mean coke you're right
that's an exception and there are always
exceptions but let's be honest is care
for lawns gonna be that exception is it
gonna be the next Coca Cola or does it
make sense to just choose a better name
think about then since you brought up
exceptions one of the biggest is using
your own personal name a bunch of
empires were founded this way but even
these will get some adjustment in order
to really succeed Bruce Lee's birth name
is mostly unknown for the West Jesus
Christ got shortened Oprah's given name
was actually Orpha I think I'm getting
it but what about those giant faceless
corporations that still show up in full
yep another good point Matt you're right
they have extra unappealing names and
they sort of run the world which prison
yes you can't have a giant Empire even
with a crappy name but your name won't
be well-known is that really what you
want look at Capital Group companies
Vanguard Group Inc and State Street
Corporation
seriously nobody knows these guys but
they make a lot of money
they control huge chunks of the economy
but who looks up to them who's inspired
button how will history remember their
name compared to say Amazon what if they
did all their same work you know
dominating the economy but also how to
cool is name the green that's definitely
better right and since you can do better
than matte landscaping Group
Incorporated why not do it your own is
something with Sylvan just ditch the
scaping part and trim it down to
something punchy like just so exactly
still brilliant tattoos and t-shirts
Matt can't you see it that name is
empire level yes I can see it it's way
better than calculon's
yeah and you deserve the best I'm white
your empire to grow a name like silk can
leave a legacy and all it took with a
bit of investment into your name you'll
give it more meaning through what you do
and the value you provide but it's also
valuable on its own by design well named
Matt well name Matt went on to become a
leader in natural sustainable
landscaping but he likely would have
plateaued with his original name names
are power use yours wisely rise and
believe altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you like this video
and you want to learn how Steve Jobs
came up with the name Apple for his
company check out the video right next
to me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there simply decided that you're gonna
call it Apple Computer suggested a
better name by five o'clock that day